from the AP the US will send a carrier
strike group to the Eastern
Mediterranean in support of Israel so
this news came just the other day it's
on top of what we're hearing now from
CNN that the US is offering Special
Forces as several of the hostages or
some of the hostages taken are believed
to be Americans I was saying this the
other day my concern is if Americans are
captured and some of these uh one one of
the one of the one of the individuals
that's taken hostage is an IDF soldier
who is a dual citizen American and
Israeli which creates all sorts
questions about should the US be
involved no question the us is going to
use that they're going to say that's an
American citizen despite the fact it was
also an Israeli citizen fighting on
behalf of Israel you know in a conflict
but now with the deployment of a car
carrier strike group I'm I'm curious the
The Chance by which the US gets involved
in a direct conflict which is a dam
dramatic escalation and and what could
possibly happen do you think the U I
mean look the US is involved this is it
deploying a carrier strike group isn't
involvement but where where do we see
this
going um Hezbollah took out an Israeli
Cruiser class ship in 2006 with I think
a French exos set missile that was
smuggled in it was one of their
surprises so they in the southern
Lebanon have the capacity to take out
ships I don't think they'd be stupid
enough to do this but you now have us
Assets in there that are just a trigger
point for World War III it would
probably be better if there were fewer
us assets in the area honestly just
because just like it's it's then you
have is this in in 2014 I remember uh
protective Edge kicked off and I'm
hanging out with a bunch of journalists
and they were concerned about a very
slim possibility of World War III that
actions taken against Gaza could incite
Iran and then Russia and then China and
then you get you know much like the
assassination of France Ferdinand was
not to at that time when that happened
nobody said that's it it's World War I
like the World War started no no the
assassination happened it got reported
and then over a long period of time
treaties kick in eventually it's called
the Great War We Now call World War
World War I there was fear that
protective Edge could lead to something
like that but ultimately it didn't it
was 51 days now with this with the us
being more directly involved with the
active war in Eastern Europe which is
very much related to energy Syria the
Syrian conflict and Iraq and a bunch of
other countries and then the fear that
China moves on
Taiwan we could be really knocking on a
legitimate World War II knocking on the
door of yeah I mean and I think Syria in
a lot of ways was kind of a a laboratory
or sort of a a test case for World War
III because you had Russia coming in
with Iran and Hezbollah to stop us and
Western proxy forces who happened to be
aligned with Al-Qaeda and Isis and
Israel was actually supporting Al-Qaeda
and Isis in the Golan it was giving them
weapons it was allowing them to pass in
and out of the Goan actually Moshe ya
Alon who was the Israeli defense
minister at the time this is a headline
I would prefer Islamic State to Iran in
Syria in The Times of Israel you can
look that up um so now now is that
because of the difference between the
Shia and the Sunni Muslims that and that
they are just weaker and they don't want
to fight Israel because in many ways
they're just a creation of the West um I
mean if there is a regional War all
those Al-Qaeda forces and idlib in Syria
that resist that fought the Syrian
government they're not going to be
fighting on um against Israel and
they're kind of like on Israel's side
Al-Qaeda and Isis I mean just think
about that but uh what could happen here
that I think could set the region on
fire is and it's already happening
anyway is if Israel tries to march on
Gaza City uh it would be a disaster for
them they'd lose so many people there
would be thousands and thousands of
casualties inside Gaza it's not
favorable terrain for Israel didn't uh
IDF go on the ground in 2014 yeah they
did didn't go very well for them they
went into an area called shuay East of
Gaza City and lost something like 40
soldiers including officers they totally
underestimated the alasan brigades the
armed wing of Hamas and they retreated
and then blanketed the whole area with
howitzers and missiles which is why that
if you look at the rubble from 2014 it's
that area I've been there we've filmed
it it's in our film killing Gaza but if
they go all the way to Gaza City and
they're already softening it up they've
like destroyed an entire neighborhood in
the center of Gaza City where all the
administrative buildings are all the
cafes the middle class lives if they go
all the way there and they try to bring
down Hamas and occupy that area
Hezbollah will have to enter they will
not allow Hamas to fall they basically
have an informal treaty and then what
can Hezbollah do they are so much
stronger than hamas's armed Wing they
can actually do targeted strikes
throughout Israel they uh gave Israel a
bloody nose in 2006 Israel failed to
defeat
them uh and I don't know where that will
lead it could it could then lead
to more forces intervening because that
be that'd be Sunni Shi then agreeing
with each other if isbah and Hamas agree
that Sunni and Shia Muslims agreeing to
be against Israel right so isn't that
open a whole another cem of War as well
it's like with Iran backing Hamas which
is
Shia and Sunni Etc wouldn't that's
that's a whole thing in itself already
well that's a that's a great question to
raise because Saudi Arabia which we had
thought of as sort of the the the the
real Sunni power that was supporting the
overthrow they were supporting the
overthrow of Syria they're different now
Muhammad bin Salman has kind of turned
his back on the West and his statement
on what happened on October 7th uh the
attacks inside Israel was kind of he
didn't condemn it he said we just call
for peace and Washington's furious at
him um you know our gas prices are going
up right now yeah he's he's he's not
he's not opening up the tap he's pissed
off what's the story of Hezbollah who
are they where did they come from hez
Bola is a Shia faction in Lebanon uh
that
was really formed in the 1980s when
Israel invaded Lebanon Israel thought
that the Shia because they were a
minority that had been mistre greed
would be their allies and that they
would greet them with candy but then the
Israeli forces started abusing them
Hezbollah formed uh after the Iranian
Revolution with some support from
Iran and they became one of the most
powerful forces in resisting Israel as
it consistently attempted to occupy and
reoccupy Lebanon and they are
responsible for forcing Israel out
completely in 2000 they acquired
anti-tank weapons
uh they were um training in Combined
arms tactics and in 2006 Israel again
attempted to destroy Hezbollah remember
condesa rice called it the birth pangs
of the new Middle East um basically a
test case for the war with Iran and they
repelled Israel when Israel came in
again with tanks um and Hezbollah has
only gotten stronger they are led by a
political Wing Hassan nasrala is their
spiritual leader and he is an he is an
of Iran but not a proxy he's very in
some in many ways he can influence the
Strategic calculus that Iran makes and
they do also have Christian supporters
because uh they are in in in they're
like a state within the Lebanese State
and they prioritize resisting Israel
which is really popular there whereas
the Lebanese Army is totally trained by
the us just like the Palestinian
Authority they're there just to keep the
peace they don't do anything when is
Israel attacks and Israel has done so
much damage to Lebanon that PE that
Hezbollah is just popular and Hezbollah
intervened in Syria in order to defeat
Al-Qaeda I actually went to one of the
villages where they intervened called
malula which is the oldest Christian uh
settlement in all of the Middle East
actually uh The Passion of the Christ if
you saw that all of the extras from The
Passion of the Christ came from malula
they speak um Aramaic one of the last
places in the world Aramaic is spoken
and alqa took over wow Turkish NATO
backed forces of al-Qaeda and Kat back
and they took the nuns hostage so uh and
and Hezbollah came in and liberated that
town so can we pullan Town pull up this
uh we have this map here and uh take a
look at Iran look where Iraq and
Afghanistan are most people don't know
their geography no and so uh when you
wonder about the US involvement in
Afghanistan and Iraq and uh uh the US
has uh consistently been trying to uh
you know what what whatever you want to
say like they these these elements
within the US government want war with
Iran and when you understand the uh uh
cter turke pipeline as one small story
and all of this I would I I I would say
on the surface it seems that all of this
everything we're talking about is about
supplying Europe with cheaper energy to
compete with us adversaries yeah
controlling the trade rout would you
agree or what do you think um when
the US began sanctioning
Venezuela and Iran it had to then take
its oil from Russia right and now we're
sanctioning the crap out of Russia so
the oil prices are going up and Europe I
mean they're screwed Germany doesn't
have a plan B you know the green party
is in part of is in their governing
Coalition they wanted to take even
nuclear offline now they're bringing
what 26 Coal Fired plants back online
why why are they doing that why why not
just go nuclear because they're the
green party I mean it's completely
ideological this is insane um so the
point is more people need to hear this
isow this is blowing back this this
entire drive for war with Iran regime
change in Venezuela having uh you know
turning Ukraine into an Unsinkable
aircraft carrier it's destroying it's
destroying Europe which the US kind of
likes for now because we sell them our
liquid natural gas that they weren't to
buy but it will eventually come back
here and it's hurting the American
Consumer already everybody's feeling it
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 pm
and become a member over at timcast.net